we're going to jump to this story get
what go broke because this is a good
this is a good example we got the story
from yahoo washington examiner um
subway franchisees want to drop megan
rapido's new adam at olympic controversy
i think this is a really good example of
cultural and political decay
not only that it's a get won't go broke
right so they they the subway has that
commercial with megan rabineau and she
kicks the sandwich at some guy and he
catches something like that i don't know
it's one of those ridiculous yeah the
subway sandwich but then she kneels at
the olympics and that's a very overtly
political move and gesture which puts
you at odds with half the country if you
don't kneel nobody cares if you do kneel
you've made half the country angry so
now the subways so the subways the
subway franchisees are saying that
they're going to be losing money let me
read the story and then we'll we'll get
into it
uh from the examiner they say subway
subway keep doing it again you got this
subways samwise gamgee subway
franchisees are in discussions to drop
team usa soccer star megan rapinoe from
a new ad amid her national anthem
protest the 2020 olympic games in tokyo
rapido who signed with the company as a
spokeswoman this spring regularly pushes
her political views usually calls for
equal rights and an end to the gender
pay gap these views are getting in the
way of the company's reputation and
sales some of the store owners argued
during a discussion forum last month
at the event hosted by the north
american association of subway
franchisees franchisees discussed
removing rapino from a new ad where she
kicks a soccer ball at a person holding
a burrito citing complaints they have
received from their customers about her
quote
boycott subway until subway fires the
anti-american megan rapino the creep who
kneels for our beloved national anthem a
wisconsin store operator red from a note
a customer taped to the glass door of
his restaurant the ad should be pulled
and done with the franchise he
subsequently argued it gets tiring
apologizing the subway company doesn't
own any of its nearly 22 000 stores but
charges franchisees 4.5 percent of their
revenue to you for the use of its brand
and national advertising campaigns
these campaigns an arizona franchisee
argued at the forum should use the
revenue to advertise the product not
politics spending our money to make a
political statement is completely and
totally out of bounds
so here's what i see with this
it is pop culture for half the country
to do these things the politics are are
mostly meaningless like the the they
they often don't mean anything what is
what is what is kneeling in the olympics
what does it mean what is it doing what
is it representing you're not conveying
a strong idea it's just a general
protest move it's not advancing any
cause other than corporate politics i
suppose and signaling to half the
country that you agree with some kind of
view of the country or whatever very
much in line typically with critical
race applied principles things like the
1619 project which are are to me signs
of cultural and political decay in this
country
then you can see how it's affecting
business they're losing money now
because of it so it's enterprise now
businesses are starting to hurt because
of the weird things people are doing i
think the country is is split apart in a
bunch of different ways i think
culturally this is the best we have to
offer like okay this is a person on tv
who cares about their politics now the
business are getting hurt by it this
just says to me that we've gone from
stagnation
to decay the businesses lose money i
mean you can't do it get well go broke
we knew that something like that would
happen now they're complaining about it
what do we do do we reverse course and
say we're americans we love america or
do we keep propping up celebrities who
for pop culture points virtue signal
about how america's evil or some other
garbage
i think it's the fuel i think it's the
food i mean
dude i don't think you can like
garbage garbage out yeah you can't make
people change you have to change the the
environment that they exist within well
you can make people change but you it's
it's not like to go up to a person and
be like stop doing that
it's to be like here's the thing we're
doing that works maybe it'll work for
you you know what i mean
i think you have to start making
patriotism cool for young people like it
looks like a lot of these ideas travel
bottom up like if your parents are
telling you something you're just like
screw off right but if it comes slowly
from the bottom and the problem right
now is with elementary schools and what
they're teaching there it starts at the
bottom and it's just ruins society on
the way up that's what i think
so then how do you change that
it's uh imagine you got a jenga tower
and at the very bottom they're chipping
away at those jungle blocks and
everything else is going to come
crashing down when they do this stuff
and we're seeing the ramifications of
that
so but but i think it's a little i think
it's it's i think the stag stagnation of
our culture is is uh um
is an important point to bring up in
this context just that
at a certain point people started
resting on the laurels of their of their
ancestors
you know i guess it's like good times
make weak men as the saying goes right
so what happens when you have a horrible
barren wasteland of a country and in
order to survive you strive and work
hard and you're sweating and working
non-stop you create wealth and luxury
then your kids grow up knowing
wealth and luxury but the hard work that
as you tell them in the work they do by
the third generation it's like they say
you know wealth lasts three generations
so i don't it's almost like the the
fourth turn i suppose we're at this
point now where
yeah these kids haven't experienced any
hardship yeah they have no reason to
support the flag or the country or the
troops or anything they're just like
this country sucks it's evil i hate it
i'm mad and now from the bottom up the
kids are salty
and what happens everything falls from
you know
yeah and then i think usually when i
don't know if
the world's been in a similar situation
but i think usually when a society falls
and there's this huge war then you have
that repeat again right when i was in i
was in serbia last year and they were
just in war
with you guys i believe
in the 90s oh it sounds right yeah yeah
yeah and um they were like there's still
bombed buildings there and so everyone
there when kovit hit they're like
yeah we just we were just in the 90s
we're not doing this like we're not
doing the same thing as everybody else
we're not shutting down
like everyone else uh and there were
riots and things because people still
remembered how it was wow because
they've experienced hardship like
everyone there someone was injured or
like they remember it and here it's been
decades yes since there was vietnam war
or some sort of war or something really
dramatic and now we have kovid which is
pretty dramatic for people it's wrecked
a lot of people's lives
killed a lot of people
and so there's we're in this like
turning point where
are we going to end up you know coming
together or
is everything just going to crumble
forever how do you introducing this to
your kid
i teach this teacher that most people
are really stupid
right like she's in montessori daycare
and some kid went up to her the other
day and was like you shouldn't eat meat
you know because it comes from animals
and that's bad
and i was just like those people don't
know how to eat like lots of people
don't know how to eat and they like
their parents didn't teach them they
don't know how to eat like they're a lot
of stupid people they're gonna bug you
just like yeah okay
um yeah we've had some i have a funny
story actually so she came home and some
little boy came up to her and was
telling her she wasn't allowed to draw
and i was with my dad at dinner
and i was like okay you can ignore those
people just tell them to bug off i was
like just telling the bug off because
they're a lot of annoying people they'll
bug you you're allowed to draw if you're
allowed to draw
and my dad came in and was like just
sock him
just saw him and i was like that's fine
that's what he taught me when i was in
kindergarten was just like i never
socked anybody in kindergarten but like
just sock the biggest kid or if anyone
bugs you sock them so he's teaching my
four-year-old to punch so we're teaching
and i was like okay that's fine like you
know she can tell we're joking maybe
she's four and so it was literally the
next day she came back and she's like i
punched somebody
and i was like oh my god we have like
this was supposed to be a joke and now
like you got into a physical fight at
school and you're four
um but it turns out the little boy came
over the same one that told her not to
draw and pushed her oh and she punched
him back and i was like okay in that
case good for you yeah self-defense yeah
i was worried your dad was trying to
radicalize children into
violence you know but i'm glad it was
just
it was a joke but she took it seriously
yeah good for her did he ever beat up a
bully growing up
my dad
i don't think so no he was pretty small
like he's tall now he's six two but he
was uh he skipped a grade so he was a
year younger than everybody so he was
the one who was bullied right and he was
super mouthy so he was really bullied if
i could do it all again if i was four
jack him in the face yeah yeah so no no
no violence violence no no no but what
do you think when a bully attacks a kid
is the kid justified in fighting back
self-defense
yes 100 otherwise you're also gonna get
you're gonna get bullied forever like i
have friends and they they go to a
teacher or something they do it that way
and then you just get picked on forever
i got picked on a few times and i
switched into like if you do that again
i'll break your nose because i know how
to break noses it was very dramatic but
it was like okay and that stops things
right away but if it's like oh no like
don't do that or go talk to an adult
you're just gonna get tortured
throughout high school so yeah
self-defense for sure i i mean if if if
you have the there's this uh there's two
really great videos they're both from
martial artists giving advice and one
guy this great video where he's like the
ultimate technique to win any fight and
everyone's like crowding on all these
students want to hear from the martial
arts master of this ultimate technique
and then he's like this one move will
guarantee you will win any fight and
then he stands there and then as soon as
they say fight he turns around runs and
he's like he just runs away and then
everyone starts laughing and clapping
and he's like any fight you get out of
unscathed is a fight you've won
you know and he's less crude but it's
like the saying goes you know if you get
into a pissing contest you just get
covered in piss so you get into a fight
with somebody
you're going to get hurt if you have the
opportunity not to to avoid it somehow
and that includes getting picked on all
the time you have to but if you're in a
position where someone's attacking you
you need to defend yourself i don't know
if i agree with that like people get
tortured throughout high school some
people are just like picked on and
picked on and picked on and their entire
social circle falls and they end up as
the outcast i think if you're in that
kind of situation you end up punching
someone who's picking on you i think
that's the way to go but i think we're
saying we're not necessarily disagreeing
if you're if you are defending yourself
from someone attacking you like you have
to defend yourself but even if it's
attacking with words
what do you mean well i mean picking on
i don't mean picking on physically i
mean like i went to an art school nobody
fought anybody there but there was a lot
of bullying
over social media or just in person or
behind
your back i don't know just i think like
a solid
just that's how i manage it like i'll
i'll hit you if you keep doing this i i
love that was it tyler the creator i
can't remember where he was like how is
cyber bullying a real thing like just
close your eyes
just like turn the screen off
you can't though not with social media
now i mean we're we're live i mean
if i if i engaged with every nasty thing
someone said about me online i wouldn't
have a job i'd be too busy having to go
through i just ignore it all i just
they're off that's fair but high school
yeah because then you'll go into school
on monday and then people if you hear
them whispering about it yeah yeah
as a girl no but i think it's a
different level as a girl i really do
like i don't think i think that men are
more likely to get into physical fights
and women are more likely to destroy
your life by forming little posses and
being like oh yeah this person slept
with that person even if you didn't like
it gets mean and dark and can like
destroy you he's got to be above it i
think you know i always i would have i
think you haven't been a high school
girl i mean i haven't but here's what i
would explain to my friends right
there were people who would fart in
class and then turn blush red and
everyone start laughing and laughing at
them and pointing like hey you're far
they'd be like shut up no i didn't shut
up yeah yeah and then there were the
other people more like me who would hey
hey ian
and laugh and everyone's like oh you're
a jerk i'm like i don't care i'd do
whatever i want you can't make fun
because i don't care about what you
think so if you go into school and
you're worried about everyone's thinking
about you you're the person who farts i
think it's embarrassed okay we're on the
same page then here because how i
countered
bullying from women was not only doing
the not caring but also addressing it
being like don't talk [ __ ] about me
unless you want to fight like seriously
straight up so it wasn't
i think that's a similar page but like
shirking away from it and ignoring it
certainly didn't work with women i just
kind of feel like right now you know
i've dealt with this a lot of people
have dealt with this a lot of people get
so stressed
you know working in in in politics and
culture
being online it's it's endless
harassment i mean the the death threats
and the creepy comments and just the the
insanity and i'm just like i don't care
dude you know sit in your little room
say whatever you want to say i just
don't care i'm going to keep doing my
thing and you know what it's like i
guess eventually it could be a hoard of
zombies piling up in front of you know
my car and then my car stops that's okay
well i guess it happened but i see all
these lies all these all the all the
manipulation all the lies all the smears
i'm just like dude
i don't know you and i don't care what
you think and you are free to hate me
you know it's like i get i get
journalists being like so and so i made
this accusation about you and i'm like
so and so can call me whatever they want
they're allowed to believe whatever they
want to believe i don't care
did it go on for like 10 years or 15
years though what do you mean the the
abuse the bullying people bro it has
been a decade of me doing public
political not only i mean in person
because what i think what's happening
the reason why i was physically attacked
during occupy wall street
every school is a kid like i think a lot
of the kids that are i didn't grow up
with social media so it i didn't have
this this level of abuse where like it's
also happening when you're at home i
would go into school i'd get pushed
around a little bit
and then i would leave school and it'd
be done and i i just left school i was
14. you left school i was like i'm out
don't waste my time i wonder if the
social decay is related to the kids
growing up in this environment yeah an
interesting social media
probably what did michael males say that
pr uh schools are one of the only places
that children will experience violence
right you did yeah they're they're like
little prisons like we yeah dude
jordan's boring example of the evolution
of education because he left that system
and now he's teaching online in a
voluntary system where people can come
when they want listen as long as they
want and then leave that's that's how i
uh when i was i've had the internet
since i was a little kid we had
compuserve on dos so i grew up with aol
in early stages windows three from from
dos shell we had we had dos then we had
dos shell we had windows 3.1 what was
the other windows the one we had the
original windows we had we had all of it
i was
no no windows
i don't know it was the one where it was
just gray boxes and you'd like before
3.1 yeah yeah and then we had 3.1 then
we had 95. i was on aol the whole time
we had aim cable internet came out we
got cable we were on instant message the
whole time i have been on the internet
and i was able to google search websites
i was able to talk with other people and
that allowed me to experience the real
world from adults
and not of all and not pretty at all but
hey look the internet's a nasty place
but then there's a big difference
between when you're a kid and you're in
school and the teachers treat you like
an other like you're not an adult you're
not to be talked to like an adult you're
not to be taught like an adult you
actually get raised by the children
around you so it's no no wonder that
millennials are basically permanent
children
i grew up with the internet where i was
there was adults on forums talking about
music and things like that that i was
into and game development and so there
would be someone be like hey here's how
you do x y and z and they wouldn't treat
me like a child because they didn't know
all they knew was someone said hey how
do you do the parallax scrolling thing i
saw in that video game it's really
really cool and they say oh here's how
you do it here's the code and and then
i'm back awesome and then i go and do it
i think you're right and i think that
compounding this being raised by other
children is the fact that you can
literally always run to a parent or an
adult when something goes wrong and i
really think that's a huge problem now
in the colleges you see these students
who are incapable of handling even the
slightest amount of like friction when
it comes to their world view and that
makes them intolerant and makes them
need safe spaces it's actually a really
big problem
it happens on twitter man people are
like he said that word let's get them
yeah what are you doing what authority
are you obsessed with as well also is
that's the biggest problem in your life
like what is because what can what do i
do to get that to be the biggest problem
in my life someone said this word on
twitter that's what i want my problems
and life to be what i'm saying thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you